okay going live live okay and we are
live hello everybody and welcome to
round table with the stream team and
this is when we come here and talk to
our constant creator friends about their
journeys and you know their hobbies and
you know what you know what what they're
doing today and that you know how they
how they kind of grew with their with
their content creator community today we
actually have a very good friend of ours
from from Hogue law his name is richard
Hoke or as other like to call him you
know aka mr. virtue or legality so how
are you doing how are you I'm doing okay
I'm not infected with anything as far as
I know this evening so we're doing all
right so far
Oh perfect perfect got your vaccine in
you're all good I'm sad I'm unlocked
down here in my office good
so we also have our our other friends
here to you this evening we have mr. MJ
is a boss how you doing bud what's
poppin what's poppin uh nothing actually
doing pretty damn well doing good
hanging in there still recovering from
packs what other than that doing
fantastic so good I'm happy happy that
he you know you're able to come I hope
you're enjoying your spring break are
you aren't you on spring right now yeah
yeah yeah it's just you're relaxing yeah
I'm glad midterms are over good good are
you at least getting a little gaming in
tiny tiny bit of gaming good they gotta
make it you gotta play catch-up my man
make sure you don't have too much of a
backlog what game it's called ketchup
you said yes ketchup ketchup okay my
friend Pedro yes yeah you got that so
and then we have our lady of the group
our good friend l-boogie oh 208 how are
you doing now hellooo how are things
been pretty good yeah I was sick last
week though oh that's a good thing we
didn't ever show last week how did you
feel when I sent you
that message on the show floor of Animal
Crossing upset because I said get me
something hey man you didn't respond so
well I'm sorry did you respond to me oh
I'm sorry did I tell you of the debacle
of animal crossing that I had happen so
so a little quick paksy story for
everybody so when we were doing when we
went to the Animal Crossing booth we
ended up to me and in Lord gene we ended
up doing a little bit of gameplay and
you know you can check us out on you
know the iron Lords podcast YouTube page
and we finished the show we finished
doing everything and they were like okay
guys you got to move here so we kind of
they kind of forced us into a corner and
they were like you must stay here and I
was like this is like media hour we have
like an hour to see as much as we can
and then there was just like you could
not leave and they're like Caleta stay
they made us sit in the corner and I was
like could we go now they're like no and
then the other woman that we were with
in our group was like you can't hold me
here and smack the velvet rope so it
like kind of just like fell to the floor
and step back and she's like see ya and
she walked out and I was like buh-bye
just followed her and she followed me -
it was one of the funniest situations
but it was just like oh my god I had
only Nintendo would try to like hold you
there for the full media hour so you
didn't see anybody else no this is great
but but yeah I was thinking of you if it
makes you feel any better it doesn't
you're supposed to get the pen so what
something wait pins are being napkin or
something issues another oh I'm certain
well I should have taken a picture I'm
sorry daddy who the booth was huge and
I'd like a full Animal Crossing like so
last year at e3 when they had the Zelda
thing like that she was like all
encompassing Nintendo booth huge
well hopefully e3 this year if it goes
off yeah yeah I'm hopeful but I still
think that they're gonna use this as an
excuse
yeah I feel the same way that's I and I
don't I don't want to discuss it because
it's just gonna make me and everybody
else mad so so but anyway anyway we're
here for hope it's but as everyone knows
it's me Pete also notice now though here
you know kind of steering the ship if
you will for for our show um and as you
guys know taxis amazing was they're
super busy it's been fantastic and
everyone else is listening
hello and welcome thanks for joining us
if we lose internet connection I am so
sorry but absolutely it's been good
knock on wood hopefully it doesn't break
if it does not work I'm sorry but I
still love you
so anyway mr. Hoge that's so so why
don't you go ahead and tell us about
your you know you being a content
creator why you decided to start one
your whole journey of like why you went
from I'm going from law like from being
a lawyer into being a content creator
lawyer and and tell us about that
because you know what most people are
like I'm a lawyer this is gonna be
fantastic and then they don't think hey
I'm gonna make virtual legality to make
a You Tube page like this and it's gonna
be keep going with it so what's good and
tell us about it yeah you know I think
it's a multi-faceted process for me it's
just the typical story of a venture
capital and mergers acquisitions lawyer
that just one day decides to start a
YouTube channel but that's really my
background so I went to Michigan law
school I graduated now eons ago in 2005
I worked in Ann Arbor for the bulk of my
career doing law in mergers and
acquisitions in venture capital helping
tech spin-offs from the University and
essentially my story in terms of
software and technology from a
professional basis kind of begins there
so 2008 rolls around and I'm a venture
capital lawyer and as you probably are
aware of in 2008 2000
9 a lot of people weren't investing
money and a lot of stuff was a downturn
in the economy and my firm came to me
and said that's fine you know we're in
this together but you need to go find
another specialty and figure out what
you're gonna do to help the firm and so
I looked at what I was doing I looked at
what I liked and I said I love
technology I love software I've had a
lifelong love of video games which
really came from my father my father was
the kind of guy that in the 80s we had
the Atari 2600 and we had the old Mac
with the cardboard chimney on the top of
it and we had an in television we had I
still have my Intellivision and it works
and I use it and it's one of those
things that my parents are like I'm like
no because it still works but anyway I'm
sorry no no not at all no so so I you
know I went through my life you know I
remember my dad sneaking a Super
Nintendo to me and my brother without
telling my mom and so you know we had
and we had everything yeah I just really
love technology his dad was a scientist
and so we just had this kind of love of
it so we had a CDI we had a turbo
graphics we had a 3do and and that just
kind of continued and continued and
continued so in 2008 I'm looking at what
I want to do I say hey you know software
is a service which Microsoft had really
only flipped to Oracle it really only
flipped to kind of a little bit earlier
than that my firm biggest law firm in
Michigan had a small group handling it
didn't have a ton of people doing
software and in particular SAS so I said
all right I'm gonna learn that I'm gonna
go I'm going to read some treaty seas
I'm gonna go and attend some seminars
and I became the software guy in the
software custom development contract guy
and all this kind of stuff and doing
that I met a lot of cool people I met
some people that were making you know
augmented reality dragons to pop out of
mall kiosks and all this very cool stuff
that is what I really love about working
and what I work in which is you know
helping generally small businesses get
formed and funded and I tell people you
know I do the tech spin-offs from
university that have all this cool
biopharmaceuticals and and life sciences
stuff and now software stuff and video
games stuff and I love that I call it
you know James Bond technology you would
not believe some of the stuff
that's kind of on the way and that's
what I really love I love that
entrepreneurial spirit I love kind of
working with those people and so my
initial goal working at the firm was to
be made equity partner right that's what
you see in all the Disney movies and all
the television shows you want to make
partner and you put in the hours and do
all this stuff and I was made partner in
2014 and that was great I accomplished
my goal and I looked around and said I
don't really want to just do this
forever
so 2015-2016 I start thinking about what
I'm gonna do instead 2016 I leave to
start my own firm actually with a buddy
who was a good friend of mine still a
good friend of mine and we left to start
a firm together and after a little while
a little bit of time it was clear that
that particular buddy wasn't enjoying
the entrepreneurial endeavor as much as
he thought he would before he left
so he decided he wanted to go back to
big law don't blame him
salary checks are nice rather than
wondering where the next bit of money is
gonna come from but that left me looking
at start having my own firm we're
deciding to go back myself so in 2016 in
the fall I decided to start Hogue law
and just kind of figuring out how to
order order toner and what you know
assistants had been doing for me for 13
years and just kind of figuring out how
to operate was its own kind of adventure
for six months and then 2017 I start
deciding okay we're gonna put marketing
dollars in play because we don't have
the name of a big firm we're gonna
figure out what we're gonna do and in
2017 rolls around and I see that the
game trailers folks had gone off and
done their own thing which they call
easy allies and they had a sponsorship
that was open and I was sponsoring
various things that I liked Soho claw is
a sponsor of MgO blog because I'm a
Michigan Wolverine til the day I die
and so we sponsor that and I talked to
those guys I'm on their podcast we have
fun with that and I sponsored easy
allies for more than two and a half
years really right up until just before
they wound up ending their patreon
sponsorship so you can't even do that
anymore and in doing that I I don't know
if you follow the easy allies
if any of yours or let's watch them well
as part of their show their main podcast
they wound up having a few legal
questions and so Kyle bossman who heads
their podcast would contact me and he
would ask me a question about the Bungie
Activision contract which leaked when
the infinity war lawsuit happened or
about whether fan games are infringing
on publishers copyrights or why they
exist or why shouldn't they exist or
what you know just general concepts
about those kinds of things and he would
ask me the questions and I would send
them big long lawyer he answers which
were hopefully simple to understand and
this became a segment on easy allies
called help us out hub which I think
they're about a dozen of and so I kept
doing that and and then I was marketing
myself on the radio so I was here
locally in Ann Arbor
doing a radio show for the Michigan
Wolverines kind of sports broadcast and
midday which got me a couple clients and
I found that I was doing that pretty
well you know I get paid to talk so it
is what it is but with those kinds of
his background with people enjoying the
helped us at Hoag segments in a video
game context which I wasn't really
expecting with the radio success that I
was having and then with wanting to see
how YouTube worked because at the same
time I had gotten a couple of clients in
the video game space and in the software
space that had their own YouTube
channels were working through a few
things and we're getting specific data
and they wanted to talk to me about it
and I just a curious person wanted to
know more about what YouTube says to you
as a content creator what data it gets
what it gives to you those kinds of
things I basically started up a channel
and that was virtual legality and so
virtually galatea is essentially a show
where I try to take pop culture concepts
a lot of video games but also movies
television shows things that are in the
news that hopefully if you just kind of
thumbing through whatever it is you're
thumbing through on the internet you're
otherwise interested in but that has a
business or legal component and then I
drill down
on what that business or legal component
might be hopefully you know six or seven
notches below what a legal brief might
look like so that more people can be
informed about not exactly the specifics
of every granular detail of the law but
why they are seeing things happen the
way they are happening you know why
Microsoft might buy this company and not
this company what a company has to deal
with when they are under potential
acquisition terms and why you hear about
contracts being signed but closing is
six months later you know we covered the
the Fox Disney deal which took like
eight months between signing and closing
because they had to go through all these
regulatory things but through that that
the channel was really formed because
I've got this experience I've got this
knowledge I've got this passion for you
know nerdy stuff I love all this the
stuff and I think taking these difficult
concepts these kind of cold concepts
like business and law and looking at
them through a prism of the stuff that
you're otherwise interested in where the
hell is spider-man
why are Disney and Sony fighting about
him can can get you a better
understanding of what are otherwise
these difficult concepts and hopefully
I'm doing a good job of that I've been
very surprised and happy with the growth
of the channel but it's been a journey
it's it's interesting to see what works
for people what doesn't work for people
and you know as I've gone along virtual
legality really only started in November
of 2018 so we're you know 15 months old
do you ever take yeah and things have
been going well I will say that I I do
listen to to some of the you know tacos
did you come up with oh god don't listen
to him all all I I've got to tell
everybody that I work because you know I
like to I need some background noise so
yeah I go through my set podcast I want
something a little bit podcast I start
hitting the YouTube pages up and I I
kind of think of your channel more like
a a Neil deGrasse Tyson version of law
like you know he always talks about
physics and the Stars and everything
like that and kind of brings it down to
you know the cultural like you know
stigmatism zuv now
so when you
kind of communicate you kind of do the
same thing but in a legal standpoint and
the the geek nerd type communication how
it is now which is pretty much a very
large standard that most people can
understand yeah
would you use it would you say that's
kind of how you kind of thought of going
through the process yeah first of all I
think that's a high compliment because I
think Tyson does a great job of breaking
down really complex things as a
non-scientist so I always enjoy that
yeah I mean I think the other kind of
component to that in terms of video
games and pop culture in general is I
was also seeing a large amount of
divisive nasaan line in in communities
that I love right I mean I love video
games I love Star Wars I love all these
things that have you know to be honest
on the Internet a lot of people you know
nipping at each other at all times and I
do think that some of that is never
going to go away because some people are
angry they like to be angry they like to
be trolls whatever it is but a lot of
people come at these things essentially
from a from a lack of understanding of
just somewhat kind of the machinery at
work as to you know what a board of
directors is looking at visa vie
fiduciary duty and what that means for
whether or not there should be micro
transactions and what it means to be the
fiduciaries of another person's money in
in kind of the video game landscape that
doesn't mean they make every decision
right god knows Electronic Arts I've had
enough virtual legalities talking about
their decision making but it does mean
that when we can understand what a Board
of Directors does what the object of an
officer's role in a corporation does
maybe if you are angry about something
with respect to battlefront 2 or
what-have-you
you're angry in the right direction you
know you're focused on what the issue is
you're focused on what the mistake is
and kind of not making everybody
miserable kind of just flailing at
various things and you know my late my
most recent videos they've gotten a lot
of traction in the last couple days are
about invidious g-force now and we don't
need to go into all the details about it
but there are confusion points amongst
fans about how software licenses work
what Nvidia is doing
why they probably need a license to do
it why they don't have one and hopefully
you know one of the things I try to
impart on people in the video is I'm not
telling you to like this I'm not telling
you to even not put pressure on folks to
change things I'm telling you what the
status quo is right now how these
licenses work together how the law works
so that you can understand what these
current state of play is which parties
have the leverage and which don't and
direct yourselves appropriately in terms
of who to be angry at even and I
hopefully can bring a little bit of that
I generally think of myself as a
somewhat kind of sober thought-process
type person on these questions for the
most part because I'm a fan of
everything you know I'm I'm an eternal
optimist as I know you all think of
lawyers in general we're just you know
cheery optimistic people and because of
that optimism I you know tell people
hold on hit a switch the wrong way I
tell people you know why something that
looks bad could potentially be good why
they shouldn't necessarily be angry
about something and hopefully help
enlighten or illuminate or educate or
whatever makes the most sense for
whatever topic we're talking about so
because your your videos are very
they're very detailed and there's a lot
of information and your the amount of
quality that you put into those videos
to try to push the knowledge of what you
have and what you do does it take you a
long time to produce those videos well
the good news is you know one of one of
my goals really since the start of
virtual legality in the tail-end of 2018
was trying to figure out a way that I
could make a series that I could fit
into my workday and and lawyers are very
often busy and even when they're not
busy they're very often on call my wife
likes to joke with me about the fact
that I'll tell her I've got a client
emergency or something and she's like
what is a corporate lawyer what are you
talking about it's like well what
it's an emergency in reality my client
views it as an emergency and if I would
like to keep that client then we're
gonna treat it as an emergency so it's a
service profession unlike so many
service professions you got to be able
to react so one of my first goals was
what I call how low can we get this
farm-to-table and for the first kind of
early days of virtually Gaudi was about
six hours in episode and that's not bad
for like content on YouTube it's not
great for fitting into your your legal
day yeah so I've been working since then
to try to kind of get it into a slot
where I could do one kind of frame it
out in the morning potentially tape it
then try to get into a place where
they're releasing on some kind of
regular schedule but you know the the
good news is is for the most part a lot
of what I do is kind of live and if I
don't call for do those kinds of things
I can often do it kind of live edited or
anything on the fly and so if I can do
that and it doesn't require that extra
step then I can go kind of farm to table
within a couple hours yeah and at that
rate you know I can get out a good
episode and it's very kind of you to say
they're very detailed and and you know
have a lot of depth I essentially set up
the tabs and figure out all the aspects
I want to cover and then when in my
brain I'm satisfied that we've got kind
of coverage of the major points no the
one thing I tell people a lot in virtual
legality is you know whole semesters of
classes are gonna be based on this one
point I'm gonna talk to you about for 30
seconds so you're gonna you're gonna get
a taste of how these things work but you
know this is a YouTube channel it's not
legal advice please dear God don't do
something based solely on this one
sentence but here's the gist of how the
law works in this and you have a little
bit better understanding and then
potentially do deeper dives you know
that that g-force now kind of video
series I talked about I did my normal
kind of 30 40 minute video last week and
then a lot of people commented on my
social media and my Twitter and then
comments to the videos some not so
nicely and so I did another video that
said all right I want to do a deeper
dive responding to some of these things
this one was like an hour and 20 minutes
which is not ideal YouTube hates those
plates and
but it's good like you get the
opportunity to kind of talk with people
I've done a virtually gallery live I've
tried kind of just experimenting with
that format having chat kind of talked
to me about various things and will
probably pursue some of that a little
bit more into the future but I'm still
kind of experimenting with new and
different things very rare amounts of my
content are scripted I do you know the
occasional joke virtual legality I did a
whole virtual legality which analyzed
the the failures of the easy allies to
properly adjudicate they're betting
special under the laws that they had
provided for bets of regarding III
reveals and that was all scripted out
and I used you know black and white
imagery and like deadline music to talk
about it like it was a murder and and
have fun with those kinds of things and
then in the fall of last year I had a
whole long series which you're probably
familiar with in terms of your own space
about Coppa because YouTube had the FTC
sub settlement and Everett was warning
everybody about Coppa compliance and so
a number of other content creators that
I had talked to ask me about Coppa and
so I did a couple of videos on how the
FTC works what the settlement does how
Coppa interacts with a channel creator
on YouTube what you need to know about
clicking that not for Kids button all
these kinds of things and that wound up
having some scripted content as well
where I said all right let's see if how
much I can shorten this so it's
bite-sized right because you know
obviously I get paid by the hour so I
can talk but it's often harder to kind
of distill that down to 10 minutes you
know the joke I have with people is that
some some you know you're reading reset
area reading neogaf or whatever and they
talk about all that this guy is just
filling in time to get to ten minutes
and and the joke I always have is my god
if I could bring in one at 10 minutes it
would be a miracle yeah we were in packs
a lot of the videos that we ended up
doing we we tried to we tried to push
them to 10 minutes to fill them to 10
minutes sure YouTube loves it I can't
blame anybody we want what we wanted to
get like information from people so we
kind of see that I just want to give a
quick shot
to gamer ways to obi-wan Watson X bot
Christopher or thanks guys for you know
coming and stopping by we greatly
appreciate you guys for being here so so
hope when you when you said that you
were cutting cutting your time down for
your videos alright yeah um because we
know you we've heard you speak about it
before and you have your kids and your
wife like you were saying idea how do
they how do how did they kind of
perceive it that you were making like
this YouTube page because I I'm I've
personal and family friends that are
that are lawyers also and I see how much
work and time they put into stuff and
I'm like I don't know how they have
times for a family and their job let
alone being you know a content creator
how did how did that work out for you
and for them well I mean a part of that
story right is as part of what I talked
about earlier which is you know I was at
big law I was at the biggest law firm in
Michigan and I was working enough that
yeah I looked around when I was made
partner didn't know that I wanted to do
this part of that was I was born out all
the time and I have no doubt that I
wasn't that awesome to be around outside
of work and so one of the decisions that
I made was you know we're gonna give up
big law partner money and we are going
to try to trade some of that for a more
family-oriented existence and so you
know hoga we work hard we have good
clients I have clients that I love to
death if by some chance you're watching
this I love you but it's not the same
kind of you know go find 3,000 hours to
bill type environment primarily because
you know that just wasn't what I was
interested in so you add the YouTube
channel you know ho Glauber true
legality is a marketing vehicle in part
right and that you get to do what I
think I'm pretty good at which is break
down these legal issues and you get to
talk about them and now I have you know
two hundred and four episodes of virtual
reality up there
and I can point specific potential
clients to specific videos I can talk
about what I've said I can give examples
of when I think I did a good job of
breaking down what a merger or
acquisition looks like now one of the
things I will tell you I can't promise
that this will ever come to fruition but
you know one of the things on my notepad
of possibilities to do is you know
contract breakdowns animated corporate
form breakdowns slightly more
educational material which I could
hopefully still make fun that I could
point people to even more directly those
entrepreneurs that you don't want to
know the difference between an LLC and a
corporate form what it means to be
escort versus C Corp what it means to
incorporate in Delaware versus Michigan
these kinds of concept questions that
every client winds up asking that you
could say hey here's a five minute or 10
minute case file type video check it out
and yeah that's that's me hopefully God
willing showing off and saying yeah look
at this this could be your lawyer and I
know my stuff and you know look at it on
I'm willing to put it globally to the
world and you know I now have 15,000
tweets and 250 videos and you can trust
that I'm not going to embarrass your
company like I'm out there and I not you
know I'm not saying anything you know
I'm not ninja out here saying weird
stuff yeah so you know it's part of that
in terms of the family I'll tell you
this you know I was a you know law firm
partner I'm now of counsel to a bigger
firm I've got all the business cards
with all that I've got all the fancy
diplomas on the walls and all that my
wife my wife jokingly said I don't know
what subscriber number convinced her but
she said yeah you know at the beginning
first of all I thought nobody was gonna
be interested in that at all that didn't
sound like something that anybody would
want to watch on YouTube and and then at
some point she said but I stopped being
embarrassed about telling people that
you were on YouTube a while ago this is
a conversation we had so whatever number
will you broke how many subs yeah I
don't know five maybe five thousand it's
you know it's at some point she was like
oh yeah that's okay
and I'll be honest with you I still
consider myself a lawyer first you know
that's that's how I feed my family
keep the lights on but I love talking
about this stuff the the the real trick
is a lot of what I do for a virtual
legality episode are the articles that I
would be reading anyway they kind of are
the trigger for any given video and then
the research that I would do to kind of
back up what I'm about to say or my
analysis of whatever that kind of
article brought up is kind of a little
bit of what I would do anyway so it was
about taking the time that you kind of
use in your day to get a breather or to
kind of rest between opposing counsel
conference calls or working on this you
know multi-million dollar deal and
taking that and saying okay I am going
to say things that I think are useful
that are educational that are hopefully
something that is going to be helpful to
people put it out there on the internet
and yeah if it brings in a client or two
in the future you know everybody's a
winner
yeah well because of because of you know
what you you kind of like produce your
own little niche of you know of what you
do which which is very intriguing to me
and I and I mean like I said before I
enjoy listening to what you have to say
and it's very informative and when you I
think of how to word this when you with
now that you're talking about like you
know your family with your wife and
everyone's kind of like on board and
enjoys this how are you kind of putting
your knowledge of what you're doing like
it to your kids do you kind of like
being as a content creator as like you
know doing the YouTube stuff kind of
showing them what this stuff is because
it's it's not easy to be a content
creator but at the same time like it's
not easy you know how do you kind of
like show that to your kids like how
they can kind of grow well I will say
this you know the one of the primary
things in hug house
is we have a real love for and a real
support for the entrepreneurial spirit
mm-hmm right so one of the things we had
to explain in 2016 was you know I was
taking a significant step down in salary
and so we had to cut off her child I
think as I look at my shelf full of all
the Lavos I so but what we said is you
know we were turning off some of the
streaming services that we had we were
not going to you know one or two of the
day camps that they wanted to go to over
the summer and we were making all these
choices and we had the conversation that
said you know I want to work more with
entrepreneurs and small business I want
to really kind of experience that you
know I've worked with these
entrepreneurs for more than a decade I
wanted to do that myself I wanted to
build something myself and you know so
we have that kind of love so this is
just an outgrowth of that you know they
know coke law is you know risk your
jumping off a cliff to do something that
is unusual and home law in particular is
unusual because I maintain these of
council relationships with the bigger
law firms and they allow me to have the
other firm and it's a whole thing and
you know finding your way in the world
especially as the legal practice I don't
need to get into much of the details
here but the legal practice is changing
so rapidly with the digital world that
the provision of legal services is not
going to look the same at all at the end
of my career that it looked like at the
beginning mm-hmm and kind of dealing
with that trying to be on the forefront
of that trying to you know understand
legal technology YouTube is part of that
Twitter is part of that you know when I
was coming up with my marketing plan the
one thing I wanted to make sure of was
that I was not the cheaper smaller
version of the big law firm I just left
and so that meant I wanted to be
idiosyncratic I wanted to have that
social media presence that I described
as lawyers are people to that you don't
just have to be you know a suit wearing
really formal lawyer you if you follow
me on Twitter
you'll find me talking about Michigan
sports video games you know Disney
movies Star Wars way too much Star Wars
honestly I can't talk about it
I would have died to see you like
walking to the being wearing some like
like like I was called Tommy Bahama
shorts yeah you know one of those like
flowered shirts walking into a business
meeting Billy hey guys what's going on
tell you I you know I roll my little
robot bb-8 around my office and truth
truth be told you know I I haven't worn
suits for more than you know oh god
maybe a dozen days since I left for the
most part my clients and this is a lot
of clients especially in tech don't
necessarily want that lawyer
relationship where they look like the
other you know they don't want to hire
the men in black to run their their
professional relationships because as a
lawyer you are a representative of the
client so a lot of these you know
companies want to be cool and young and
hip or energetic or whatever you want to
say and while I'm none of those things I
don't have to wear a suit while I'm none
of those things so I try to go out and
have those conversations but in terms of
my kids you know they see the YouTube
they sometimes watch some of the live
broadcast from like the other room but
they enjoy all of it you know they see
the hug law name on the building in our
in our little town Northville in
Michigan we have hats and they love that
and I try to imbue that spirit and you
know now my youngest daughter is you
know signed up to have a table at a
local Art Fair and and taking her art
and and selling it and just kind of
having that you know prior to purpose
and and I think YouTube and Hoagland
everything else goes into that my wife
has her own photography studio like
that's that's what we're about is is
kind of trying to imbue that in our kids
so I don't think it was ever kind of a
barrier but in terms of the technology
they don't really watch YouTube so they
don't I you know they certainly would
never watch virtual legality I jokingly
said when I was doing all the Coppa
stuff it's like I feel pretty confident
I can click this box that says not for
kids regardless of whether I'm talking
about video games but if you want to
come at me FTC you feel free and you
know so I'm pretty proud of where
they're at I'm proud every day and I
don't think this takes anything away
from that
and certainly you know it's kind of fun
to be you know 15 months out from
- you know one of my friends and easy
allies what mic should I get I don't how
does this even work and being able to
teach yourself something new right like
curiosity is the best best thing and so
I say alright how do you edit a video
what is it OBS do how do you broadcast a
video how can it what can you tweak how
does that interact with YouTube how does
that interact with YouTube live and kind
of learning all that stuff and then
having some success and getting you know
a little commercial check every month is
nice yeah so so you see you end up
you've done a couple of live streams on
your channel then yes I have so how how
often have you done those and are you
gonna continue to do them like going
forward for a little bit you know I'm
gonna have to figure out a place where
they work so we do that toes live dab
toes there are two hugs are better than
one my brother is a game developer at
high Moon Studios working on Call of
Duty they're a subsidiary of Activision
and he worked on Ratchet and Clank a
cracking time he's worked on a bunch of
stuff and so we do a show which we got I
think we did six episodes in the last 18
months or something that we'd like to
get to monthly we tend to do those live
because they're just kind of casual
chats about video games about what he
sees in design he plays all sorts of
weird stuff especially indie games
because he's always looking for you know
design tricks and and cool stuff that's
happening on the periphery of games and
so we have those talks those are almost
always gonna be live from now on just
because we like to have that interaction
with the chat it's helpful it's not
anything that needs to be planned the
other times I have done live episodes
are when the unusual circumstance where
something kind of pops late in the day
I've already recorded a formal virtual
legality but I think it's important to
have another one to talk about something
I think the last time this happened was
Sony dropped out of III like I want to
say at 8 p.m. or something like that and
so I just said alright I'm hitting the
button and I'm going or maybe that isn't
the most reason one I think maybe the
most recent one was the completely
random IGN article that decided to call
Tim Sweeney as having said there should
be no politics and video games ever and
so when
one of those where it's not necessarily
something where I need a bunch of
statutes or case law and I'm just gonna
talk about how ridiculous the headline
is and how the article is missing the
point then I just pull up the article I
hit the live button unfortunately I got
my settings wrong or discord or whoever
whatever I was doing got my settings
wrong so I'd sound like a robot with
like four voices but I do that and I can
do that on the fly so it's like it's one
of those where generally speaking if
it's gonna be a feisty version of me and
it's gonna be kind of more of an op-ed
than a than a legal kind of deep dive
those can be live and so that's kind of
what I'm doing for the most part what I
use now which is you know recorded OBS
and goes straight on is essentially a
live broadcast but I don't do it live in
case like today the the one that I did
right now wound up being like an hour
and 20 minutes and I wound up coughing a
bunch and so you have to go in yet that
at that so you you said that you're your
parent your father was very pro gaming
absolutely so he was very programming to
the point where I feel like your brother
since he is working as a game developer
and you are you for layman's terms if
you will more of a gaming type lawyer
why did you go towards being like a
lawyer instead of a gaming developer or
gaming type of person like you know one
of those types of branches because I
evaluated my options for career
financial success and came up primarily
with business and law in terms of things
that I also liked so you know my brother
loves games we designed a couple of apps
together loved that process made made no
money on it
but you know I'm I go back to college
and I love economics and so by degrees
in economics and then I look at that and
I say all right what am I gonna do with
this I could go to business school or I
could go to
school I love video games but it's one
of those things where I always describe
it to my brother like this it's like you
know there's a lot of restaurants I love
but I don't necessarily want to be
involved in making the food for myself
like I like the magic and mystery and
whenever you show me like how these
things work in video games I don't want
to know I don't want to see behind the
curtain because I love this stuff I'm
more of a theater patron than a member
of the drama class and so he went that
direction and you know it's it's it's a
hard life you know making your way in
the video game industry has a lot of
tumult has a lot of turnover working any
job in Southern California is just
tricky to get enough money to you know
have a family and make everything work
and I was always in kind of the focus of
staying in the Midwest
I love Michigan I always have and I got
into Michigan law school which was
essentially my dream school you know if
you're if you're applying to these
places and you you submit various
applications and you say I you know
we'll see about that one in Michigan's
atop a top ten law school and it was in
Ann Arbor I've always loved the area
I've always been a Michigan Wolverine
fan I got in and then it was kind of
okay
that's the way it's supposed to go yeah
and so I I did law and then I wanted to
do transactional law didn't want to be a
litigator you know some one of the
things that even people that contact me
online don't necessarily realize is
there's a bunch of different specialty
areas of law but the big kind of divide
is that there are litigators which are
the people you think of when you think
of law and order and everything else
they go to court they yell objection
it's Phoenix right and there are the
transactional attorneys which nobody
knows what they do that's what I've been
doing for 15 years and they put together
contracts they negotiate transactions
they do deals I love that I usually
describe it as I want to bring people
together rather than you know negotiate
their divorce and so I've been doing
that forever I love that I feel like I
have a good understanding of how
businesses think and operate and
function and that's a very useful skill
for figuring out how to negotiate
contracts and try to make sure that
everybody's happy but that your client
isn't overly exposed
- something bad in the contract language
and from that kind of skill set arose
this desire and I hope ability to
communicate what I see when I read a
sentence in a contract and what's
happening there
right so I mean Lu you can you can kind
of back me up a little on this because
you're like me you you've worked in the
vit field for a long time like when when
you when you were going for IT and we
had we had a similar type of situation
where you have to pick like your tracks
if you will like information system or
your customer service skills or or I
think the other ones a graphical artist
like you know you had to pick those
tracks like when like like hogs talking
like he had to pick his different paths
between you know going through his to
his law side or going to his like his
gaming side did you kind of feel like
that way too when you were going through
it when you win because we the way you
pictures I mean I switch like halfway
through it too because I was going to be
an accountant at first and then I got to
go to one of the firms and I was like no
way
well like I'm also like a single mom and
so she I was just like the hours that
you guys are expecting or just like not
conducive with me so um but yeah so I
ended up doing information systems
because the same school does information
systems at my schools so within one
school is accounting and information
systems so I was able to switch over
with ease and then I did the business
systems because I had a little bit of
coding but not heavy coding and yeah so
that's why I'm a p.m. now yeah that's
that's almost like everybody when they
are going through trying to figure out
which way they're going with their path
I mean like even it even MJ talked to me
about it a couple couple of weeks like
it was
he was talking about him declaring his
major in college and stuff it's it's one
of those things that I always find
fascinating to people because people
will pick where they want to go like
originally I was going to school to be a
chef I love cooking you you yeah I know
with the pizza l you're gonna yell at me
but the pizza again yes but um you know
I love to cook but then I realized I
would never be home for my family for
holidays and like that's like a huge
like deal-breaker for me and that's why
I want IT so I kind of from the way that
hug you were talking kind of you kind of
felt similar to go that that's like a
same way in terms of what happened with
me yeah you know I I'm actually you know
first of all I think it's absolutely
great when I hear those kinds of stories
where you went and you checked it out
and you change your mind because I think
that I think that too many people get
locked in and don't take that signal and
get into a place where they're much more
unhappy I usually talk to my clients
about you want to fix things as early as
possible because it's gonna be much more
expensive in terms of legal fees but
also emotionally and psychologically
going down the wrong road and having to
kind of change course then so I love
those stories because I had a number of
friends that kind of went down the wrong
path and and it was pretty obvious to
the rest of us and took a while to kind
of get back to where they were going I
didn't have that experience primarily
because I was always pretty focused on
what I wanted to do so my father who
loves video games was a lawyer and I was
in debate and I was in Model UN and that
went with my economics I got into the
law school I wanted to do and so there
weren't a lot of times where I kind of
changed course except of course that you
know I worked at a large law firm for a
long time and decided well earlier than
what I made partner if we're being
honest that you know I was going to do
something different with the rest of my
career and so that wasn't the same kind
of decision where I say only not that
etc etc but it was the kind of thing
where I say okay I want to get XY and Z
out of this relationship and then I want
to go a different direction so you know
my wife will tell you I make my
decisions and I stick with them for
forever
right right or wrong depends on the tone
depends on the mood when you have that
conversation you'll have both nails but
no it's I got into a situation where I
think I always knew that gaming was from
my personal psyche too volatile of an
industry with not enough financial
upside for me to to work within that and
I respect my brother and I love the
people that you know he was at school
with at the Guildhall down at Southern
Methodist that you know had given up
jobs to go and pursue this I think
that's just awesome and the world is a
better place for folks that do that but
it's not me it's not it's not the way
I'm built to expand on that with a
little bit of questions and stuff so
sure MJ MJ and I we nah not this past
you know 2020 but 2019 well we were when
we were in PAX East we we saw all those
indie developers right you remember them
MJ yeah yeah like and you saw how hard
they were working yeah and how they kind
of a lot of those people put things put
their lives pretty much on hold to
complete their games oh yeah you hear
about people mortgaging their houses and
things I mean it's yeah I'm glad we have
those games but man I couldn't do that
yeah
trying to think of one of the games that
like like one finger death punch like
those guys like that guy I made that
amazing game and he had the one game
which like they were just on the steam
community like destroyed him with with
questions and stuff and then we go there
and and he was probably one of the most
energetic people right and J like he is
so he was so good with it yep and he
like he wanted huge like I want people
to play my game I love it I was like
thumbs up so it is intriguing now we
were kind of we were talking about a
little before and I didn't want to I
didn't want to continue to talk about it
but um before I want to talk to you now
about it you were saying you do it with
the kid the whole stuff with the
convention
for you it's kind of its kind of
difficult for you to go out yeah well
you know certainly in my past life there
wasn't a lot of reason to I have for the
longest time taking a half-day on the
Monday of III to go you know watch the
press conferences and enjoy that kind of
stuff because I I love the industry but
it was really only after I separated off
and started hog law started marketing
with easy allies and doing those kinds
of things having the quotes in various
places like IGN that I was approached to
potentially participate in some panels
and do that kind of thing it is
something that I would like to pursue in
the future what I think I mentioned to
you before we started the show was it's
tricky you know lawyers aren't like
doctors in the same way that they're on
call and they have to run into surgery
or whatever it is that they do but we
are kind of always responsible for being
responsive to client emergencies and
hope is such a small outfit that my
clients are you know pretty close to
kind of family relationships and I can't
hand it off to person X or person Y that
you might add a really large law firm
you mostly have to start handling that
yourself so I am you know I I haven't
taken a vacation or left anywhere
without my laptop ready to go since I
started in 2016 I think everybody and my
family's kind of gotten used to that
you know I closed a really big deal up
in the woods in northern Michigan on my
cellphone which hey he's a really cool
thing that we can do in in our lives now
right but it also means that you're
constantly always a little bit available
even if you don't want to be but at
least I'm good really good story you
know ya know it does and I remember it
very vividly because I was trying to
close this deal for weeks I knew we had
a rental place we went up and I'm like
on the phone we're driving in these
backwoods streets to get to a specific
place on Lake Michigan and we get there
and I'm on this call and I get the text
that says you know when you close a deal
essentially the Fed reference number is
here the money has been transferred we
are closed congratulations everyone and
I'm like thank God you know closing is
such a weight off your shoulders because
you've been working so hard on it
for so long
and it's really cool that you can do it
in the woods it also means like one of
the things I said I didn't what's the
rental place I got up north I had to
check like six ways from Sunday to make
sure it had a strong Wi-Fi you know I
couldn't be one of these cabins in
northern Michigan that couldn't get
connected to and it's very funny because
you go and you ask for advice for this
kind of stuff online and people are
always trying to be helpful but a lot of
the advice you get is oh you should
disconnect and you shouldn't you know be
looking for that kind of stuff and it's
like I know I know I can't do that let's
pretend I can't do that
do you know which house has people try
to be helpful is like oh no you need to
you need to disconnect that's the only
way you can really vacations like maybe
that might be true however trying to
grow a small business so let's pretend I
need that Wi-Fi I will cruise in two
thousand five two thousand five or four
to five whatever it was yeah and we were
in the Caribbean and I still cellphones
still didn't have like the technology
they have today it was like a slider
phone with just you know regular like
keypad to text people back and forth
sure I remember not being able to like
text my friends that you know and I was
just like going crazy now was thinking
about all of that like because I always
have to have an internet connection
because of my job even like we're on
coal like you know one week out of the
month and you know even yeah even like
even with with COG and the podcast and
the team and everything like sometimes
she's just like y'all can you get this
for me I can't get it I'm stuck here can
you do this like I'm gonna get back up
so it's like I always have to have some
type of internet connection so I can
understand you know needing to have that
even though people are telling you to
disconnect me I will never disconnect
I'm told Pollak I think my wife will
like wants to kill me when we go on
vacation but it's one of those things
that's sometimes you know you have to
like ell when you go to Disney how much
do you love disconnecting
when you go to Disney or are you just
like Instagram posting every single food
and every single rider on no I'm like
really bad about that my friend and I'm
usually with is like does it all the
time so then like I'll start doing it
but for the most part like I just enjoy
like Disney you know it's it's this name
yeah and then on the polar opposite we
have MJ who is our snap cat snapchat
snapchat can you just invented an app
there I did let's snap cat let's call
your brother after the soak and look-see
kognito just said it he goes end damn
good backup now those OCD his saves me
countless times yes it has I can't even
tell you how many times but yes it is
good so uh MJ do you have any questions
for hope I do not thank you i-i-i-i've
so many more questions but I know enough
time right now what about you L I was
made it first second but I wanted to ask
what is like the dumbest thing you think
you've seen me do like yeah you know I
guess as far as like contracts we can
zone yeah you know I'll say this so a
lot of the times people are coming to me
right before they want to say sell their
company right I haven't been there a
lawyer maybe they haven't even had a
lawyer I do a lot of work with
family-run businesses where they're
retiring and they've had a really good
run and they're gonna make a lot of
money they're gonna go sip mai tais on
the beach or something but a lot of the
times their documentation is really
really bad and one of the pieces of
advice I try to give clients is it
really really is a lot less expensive to
get it right at the front end and just
kind of roll with that then to say okay
there's a potential buyer or a potential
investor or a regulatory agency god
that wants to look at everything we need
to have this cleaned up and it's like
okay well if we have to have it cleaned
up and that's six different repair
documents and then we have to do filings
and all this stuff and you know that's a
fifteen thousand dollar bill instead of
a three thousand dollar bill and I I try
to impress that on people but that's the
kind of stuff that I see most often
actual stupidity that probably falls
under the the realm of things like oh we
did something that wasn't allowed in our
governance documents or we needed a
board vote that we never took ten years
ago and now this person is suing us
because they think they own shares when
they were rescinded only we don't have
the right documentation for it all of
these calls of course end with me saying
let me get you a litigator and you know
that that's it but in terms of the
actual news stories you see kind of
silly stuff all the time business
decisions I like to tell people you know
one of the things you see on reddit or
neogaf or wherever you're reading your
video game news is you know these these
businesses have a hundred lawyers they
have six thousand business analysts and
so they understand what the market is
doing X Y or Z and and the one thing I
try to communicate to everybody is one
hundred percent they've got a lot of
research date and they understand why
they took this action it does not mean
it is the right action corporations are
still made up of humans making decisions
and they can make mistakes no matter how
much research they have so when we talk
about something like you know loot boxes
and oversaturation of those things that
can happen because Electronic Arts
thinks that everything needs a loot box
because they've read all the research
and then people love loot boxes but
they're operating in a universe that
hasn't existed before which is the
universe where EA puts a loot box in
every single thing that they have and so
you can still make a mistake even when
you're trying to pursue a good option
and that's what I try to impart to
people is human beings are running this
whole show but from from writing the
contracts that are the Steam end-user
License Agreement to writing the laws
that we're talking about it's humans all
the way down and everybody makes
mistakes yeah
how he describes things yeah so to the
point though it makes a lot of sense
like like you're saying if if you're
bringing everything to the table and
your first time there's no you don't
have to do it twice like that's that's
what my biggest pet peeve like I like to
do things once if we have to do it twice
so be it but if I have to do it a third
time because you're not fully giving me
information it's terrible
like I've had people I've had people in
my office come to me and go I have a
problem with my laptop and I'm like
what's wrong with your laptop and
they're like I don't know it doesn't
sure and like I take it and I open it up
and I look at it and I'm like is to keep
words not working
did something happen on the keyboard I
don't know what happened to the keyboard
and it's like I took it I open it up I
look at it I'm like you poured a whole
cup of coffee on your keyboard where
this Hawaiian Punch come from yeah like
I don't know how that happened it's like
dude just tell me you poured a cup of
coffee on your keyboard and then I
wouldn't have to waste my time trying to
figure out why your keyboard doesn't
work you know it's the truth it's
absolutely the truth it's it's just it's
just how how it is I'm sorry do you have
any more fur from now that was pretty
much the question I've been wanting to
ask this whole time something a little
more juicier well you know there are
circumstances where I can tell you that
actions that my clients have taken have
wound up in multinational litigation but
I can't actually give details on those
countries like I'll tell you later on
but I get you I understand all right
MJ you sure you're good yep okay just
want to make sure cuz kagaz coddlers
yelling at you big time in chat it's
like dad's yelling at you so um yeah
that's that's the ethics rules Lord [ __ ]
Dino hoagies no snitches actually put
into
Michigan Bar ethics rules terney client
privilege exactly so so hope why don't
you tell us wherever we can find you
your information you know where we can
find everything about you yeah
absolutely so like I said we are
marketing the law firm very 21st century
style so you can find me on Twitter
where I am commenting pretty constantly
at Hoag law spelled as you see on your
screen here h OE GLA w and otherwise on
my youtube channel which is youtube.com
slash Hoge law same spelling where we do
virtual legalities I think we're
averaging now between three and four a
week give or take now that can change on
any given week if I'm in a big deal you
know you'll see four days go by where
it's like what happened to hope I hope
we didn't die and it's you know the the
law stuff has to come first that's what
really kind of feeds the family so I'm
on there you can find me there I I
respond to as many tweets and as many
comments on my videos as I can I love to
have those discussions regardless of
whether you think I'm an idiot in
whatever I said about my video if you do
it civilly I have a saying I think
reasonable disagreement is the spice of
life I love to understand where other
people are coming from I'm never gonna
get mad at you for you coming in and
telling me that I'm wrong so come on in
follow the channel subscribe listen to
what I say about g-force now tell me how
I got every licence wrong I don't
deserve my bar license and you're gonna
explain to me exactly why copyright law
is the opposite of what I say it is I
will have that conversation and I'll
tell you why you're wrong but we'll have
a good time of it that's that's the
thing I like about if you actually read
your comments you actually you can
actually explain things in a way that
doesn't make you feel stupid hopefully
God willing some people are coming
pretty hard at me on this g-force now
stuff man is fantastic if he comes after
me it'll be in DMS or something so well
I'm very very thankful that you were
able to
I mean we you and I we've been
discussing for a long time about
probably since December for you to come
on just to kind of you know talk about
your show and everything I really
appreciate you know yeah really
appreciate the image absolutely it's
been it's been a while and very very
little little crazy on on my end from
everybody else's so now now now mr. MJ
you sir where can we find you
let's see here you can find me on
snapchat at beep 101 you can find me on
twitter and instagram at baby MJ and
what's poppin you that's about it
oh no you okay sounds good same stuff
same stuff as always so well thank thank
you very much we'll make sure we keep an
eye out and hopefully you'll get your
streams back going hopefully as soon as
you know sober get some time maybe good
I enjoy my MJ scary streams I miss them
oh god oh yes yes there will be a scary
stream no I will make it happen no you
will magically get a code in the mail
and be like MJ you must play the scary
game what scary game coming out I don't
know but I'll find one I'm scared
um Elba do 208 on Twitter and elbow do
208 on mixer and I'm there Tuesday
through Friday 7:00 to 10:00 p.m. and
then on Saturday mornings at GW Pacus on
YouTube sounds good and everybody should
definitely check them out on saw on
Saturdays
I can't the the group of ladies you have
I love them all I love listening to them
talk I love listening to your
conversations
I just the the amount of passion that
you four ladies have I can't like I
don't understand why more people aren't
watching you because you you you ladies
are amazing so just want to make sure
you realize that for me thanks
thank you spread the word oh oh I spread
the word like Corona so um so I try I
try and everyone everyone knows me it's
now though SN al why do I am on
everything pretty much Twitter Instagram
twitch from Monday to Friday except for
what I'm here
sometimes on Saturdays and Sundays
pending if my wife is working and yeah
and did in discord iron Lords podcast
discord if you want to you know get in
there you can GM me or anything and all
funds things and you know there so yes
and I like to thank everybody else are
stopping in today you know give a shout
out to a bunch of people before kognito
thanks for stopping and checking in I
hope I made your life a little easier
will have this show up on YouTube once
we are done we will have it up on all
the you know podcasts locations what's
called Spotify iTunes Google Play all
those fun things there if anyone has any
questions please email us at roundtable
stream team at gmail.com so we can ask
our questions to our guests we'd really
appreciate you doing that on this
podcast one o'clock on Sundays go check
those guys out those are our friends
over there they're great also go check
out Lords of gaming net for all your
gaming news the amount of team there I
can't tell you being able to work with
them hand in hand with packs or the only
a small group of us the passion and
everything oh your pack stuff was great
oh it was it was so good it was intense
I mean kognito he is a slave driver he
had us doing interviews every half hour
I believe that jelly from tip from 10:00
from 10:00 to 4:00 except for lunchtime
half-hour interviews and we had two
groups going nonstop and it was great
and some of the interviews we had uh I'm
speechless meeting Eric chahi meeting
all the guys from
oh my god I'm blanking on their names
like the wizard one-on-one guys and all
those guys Platinum Games meaning all
them meaning that the three youtubers
those those individuals who hoping to
try to see if we can get them on the
show you know all of them was fantastic
so it was it was great thank you thank
you for you know we're doing that cuz
that's I think that's a big deal for us
that's a great you know a lot of love
for us and as you all know this is a
roundtable with the stream team if you
go ahead and hit us up on Twitter you
can go ahead and follow us there at able
stream that's where we end up giving you
information about our guests that are
coming up when the podcast goes live and
a little I'm gonna try to give it a
little more Tibbets of information from
the other lots of gaming team and
remember everyone to dream big and keep
gaming and we will see everyone next
week
thank you and bye everybody